su opinión como a lo mejor o puede
resumir o no resumir sino los puntos más
importantes de lo que han sido estos 70
años de la reina isabel segunda en el
trono a mí lo más importante es que se
siga manteniendo la monarquía europa son
48 países de los cuales tan sólo en
siete siguen quedando monarquías y justo
la inglesa es la más rentable la más
inteligente y la que mejor lo está
haciendo porque porque ha sido la más
rentable porque ha sido digamos la más
importante la que tiene más respeto
dentro de europa incluso dentro de los
británicos
que ha hecho la de diferentes la
monarquía británica las otras mira
fíjate si es rentable que yo para
empezar tengo aquí a la solar queen
queda aquí en el bolso en el famoso
bolso de isabel le da el sol y entonces
ella mueve la mano lo veis sigo viendo
la solar way vale bueno luego tengo el
move para tomar el desayuno luego tengo
esta cosa que vale de cojín pero también
para tapar la tetera esto lo venden
para las cuánto cuesta ese cuerpo
inicial pues mira estos son los menos
mal que lo guarde la etiqueta porque
recién está a 13 libras esto significa
que la que la monarquía tiene un punto
de representación evidentemente ella no
toma partido por nadie ella no es de
derechas ni de izquierdas ni el centro y
da igual es como el final de una de una
pirámide y ya está arriba y lo ve todo
no entonces ella no toma partido por
nadie pero está allí entonces que va que
vale para eso pues porque es una
mediadora en conflictos y luego es súper
rentable
vosotros hablaréis ahora de gastos de lo
que se están gastando en inglaterra en
estos momentos con estos cuatro días de
celebraciones pero lo que están
ingresando es ingente ingente y además
no hay ningún problema esto se vende en
el palacio de buckingham pero también
hay en windsor y hay por todos los
sitios
si hay una rentabilidad un retorno
enorme y ellos mismos incluso se llaman
de firme la firma ya que es en todos los
sentidos políticamente socialmente y
económicamente rentable esto es con de
queens con isabel segunda con ella lo
que pase ya con carlos o con williams es
una incógnita ella ha sabido
mediar en los conflictos y los ha tenido
muy gordos y ha tenido muchas críticas
pero ella ha estado allí y ha sido un
punto de inflexión ella tuvo un momento
de crisis tremendo cuando diana de gales
cuando su heredero se divorcia y se
separa de diana y toda la tragedia que
fue aquello su año horrible
lo ha superado
ella tenía siempre mira está reina es
hierática se pone en las en las en las
menciones de historia un día que hizo
una cosa extraordinaria que es que fue a
pie delante de la gente hasta entonces
ella no se la tocaba ni se iba en
carroza iba en coche en lo que fuera
pero no se la tocaba eso fue una cosa
extraordinaria es de es decir ha habido
siempre como una cosa de cercanía pero
de lejanías y cercanía y lejanía y yo he
estado en los tea party en en buckingham
he estado comiendo cenando y celebrando
un aniversario de cumpleaños de isabel
ii en buckingham y es verdaderamente
alucinante
a pesar de no ser tampoco la jefa de
estado ya en este momento de india en
este momento también se están realizando
celebraciones en ese país para honrar
estos 70 años de servicio a su país de
la reina isabel segunda ahí creo que
estamos viendo unas imágenes de lo que
han sido estas celebraciones en ese
territorio en el territorio indio carmen
y le quiero preguntar la importancia de
la reina para la comunidad
o la importancia de la reina para la
cama huele inmensa de hecho lo primero
que hacen todos los miembros es hacerse
un viaje por toda la cama well ella lo
hizo ella de hecho la muerte de su padre
le pilla en uno de esos viajes visitando
todos los países son muchísimos países
aunque aunque algunos han perdido y es
lógico que sigan perdiendo no tiene
ningún sentido vamos a ver estas
monarquías y vosotros lo entenderéis
perfectamente
porque la mayoría de los países son
repúblicas son muy difíciles de entender
porque es como un dogma de fe tú tienes
que creer en ellos antes venían de dios
era una cosa como que dios te el
nombraba bueno ahora ya es más terrenal
pero son muy difíciles de entender y más
cuando se están metiendo
plebeyos en ella hasta ella se funcionó
lo de la sangre azul a partir de ella ya
se mete en otros miembros entonces estás
es muy importante para algunos países
porque ha sido como algo que les une lo
que está pasando en londres en londres
tú puedes ser en contra de la reina pero
no puedes evadirte de esta corriente de
felicidad hoy en londres es un día que
en el resto del mundo es día de diario y
ellos están de fiesta celebrando el
cumpleaños el jubileo y todo lo que
quiera isabel y eso que hoy no cumplía
años ella aún cumple en abril en abril
entonces es para para algunos países el
tener un personaje de estos es
importantísimo y de hecho ya ha tenido
se vuelcan con los países de la
commonwealth y lo primero que hacen es
viajar me hagan harry todos estos han
estado en todos los países visitando los
y también carmen como lo estaba
comentando nuestra corresponsal la reina
isabel de segunda dentro del reino unido
incluso para las personas que no la
siguen sino un sinónimo de respeto un
sinónimo de unión en el país como ha
logrado esto la reina isabel segunda
también no sé si en secreto ha sido
reinventarse a lo largo de estos 70 años
constantemente es una reina además es
que cae bien cuando estaban en la
segunda guerra mundial y era una
enfermera ayudaba y te hacían cosas para
el frente o sea es una mujer que cae
bien y cuando ha tenido problemas se lo
han dicho y ella ha reaccionado
inmediatamente a raíz de la muerte de
diana de gales estos se escondieron en
sangre en gang y el pueblo les pedía
salir salir salir y tuvieron que volver
ella rectificó ella ha sabido estar ahí
y en cierta forma pedir disculpas y
luego tienen gestos luego estas cosas de
este balcón pues esta belleza esos niños
esos colores ese bolso de la reina que
por cierto y lo echo de menos dónde está
el bolso y lo cambio por algo hasta en
esta oportunidad por un problema de
movilidad que tiene la reina ahora pero
pocos problemas ella empezó a resentirse
de las rodillas hace tiempo yo ya lo he
visto con un bastón
en un tea party de su ciudad con un
bastón
tiene una salud de hierro por favor con
96 años cómo está esa mujer si es que
hasta hace poco estaba montando en
caballo y en sant gringa no la habéis
visto construyendo su coche está esa
mujer de que está hecha no lo sé quizás
ellos tienen o no no sé les gusta la
ginebra y tal pues han por hoy quién
sabe es un buen remedio para ellos
carmen a su parecer que ha sido lo más
importante que ha hecho la reina isabel
segunda y que lo que más puede recordar
la sociedad como en agradecimiento lo
que ha hecho por su pueblo lo más
importante es mantener unida a una cama
un buen con países tan diversos tan
diferentes con tanta crispación con
tantas crisis con tanto problema seguir
manteniéndolo unido y que el reino unido
siga siendo mira cómo es esto
esto dice mucho el reino unido sigue
siendo un imperio ellos se lo siguen
creyendo
y la reina forma parte de esto aunque
sea ficticio pero es un dogma de fe es
como el que cree el que tiene una
religión y crees en dios que no ha visto
nunca esto es igual y ella les da esos
símbolos es a ese armiño esas coronas
ese oropel esas carrozas de oro ese
trekking de color eso forma parte de
toda esa mística y ella lo probó lo
promociona y luego favorece que tú
también formes parte de él porque yo no
tengo nada que ver con la familia claro
estado y a un montón de veces allí con
ellos y les he dado a la mano para
venderlo me has con el príncipe carlos
rápidamente antes antes de despedirla
pues también le quería preguntar cuando
no esté isabel quiera pasar va a seguir
esta magia 30 segunditos esa es la duda
la magia ya con carlos es muy difícil
cal carlos ha sido controvertido carlos
no se sabe si va a suceder a su madre
esto la reina muerto viva el rey no sé
si sucederá por carlos o por su hijo
william que está muchísimo muchísimo
mejor posicionado y es más empático que
es el padre lo que suceda es una
incógnita pero de momento hoy
disfrutemos del tropel de color y de esa
mujer por favor